querida la visita de la piel de los machos y la
representante de la cámara que prohíbe un
vienen los gastos le nesta intervención
que ha durado meses como máximo, ahora está prohibido
mostrar aspectos destacados aspectos destacados que no es
visto antes contundente en el como e
ex presidente donaldson sa.va néstor
cualquier acto la violencia aparte en
simpatizantes en una zona de la propia piel
lo que los convirtió en videos destacados de
puertas de la agencia de inteligencia jesi
de inteligencia solar y ataques a
capítulos o el 6 y negro mostrando i
neo se destaca que indicarán que
ataques de derecha zauri siguiendo a nia
en el capitolio da un sí llamamos en
la piel y su intervencion naima
disecciona como el presidente entonces
simplemente si escucho milar como el
pais hardy tiene inherente en el capitulo en
auto reacción una piel citando al
propio presidente y su discurso
tiene 56 twitter diciendo que es josé
simpatizante de la sabana recuerda extendido
siempre parece que ella lo amaba que sientes un
el dolor que sientes estrecho y spoleto
mar se capítulo palau l'eas che
claro que usaran rap y tiran
bari ha detenido el representante sabe
será a la habitación de la que están a cargo
de las llamadas de prueba de pigmento como impuesto
para precisamente y al sur y mostrarnos el
presidente solo sabe que si
ven violencia hasta cuando tu
presentó violencia si lo creman pida disculpas
con sólo el simpatizante atraído por
arles y consuelo de bajo las escaleras
lo despliegas a los que sienten en su salsa
sin embargo, la piel dijo cuando es
endureciendo la intervención y eso lo purificó
el presidente y ex presidente wolf e
de bombardero para desafiar un cargamento a ning
hago público que también sostiene que el
tardes cálidas es inherente lorenc f tipo hace
tambien la cédula e invernaderos y el barrio
búsqueda futura y la f de una nación
mientras no te arrepientas de eso
persona se libera a sí misma de un país como estatus
noticias de cuales machos que para el uso
estos barrio especialista de algunos
regalo este tema destaca
suficiente porque no demasiado
respiro al ghul carga pública e
masa técnica Cristo lleva entendimientos
que no se como va en trans courmayeur
timon te debo muy arduo que te del
Senado hasta 1 un voto que
el constitucional
esta procesión de juicio político y de
aver entonces sabemos si el turno de la
democracia todo arte te hizo 6 soros
máximo para spresal sobre el tema aunque
tu pais que giovanna se le rara lomas
que luego tienen los problemas en Trípoli que tienen
incluyendo acabar con toda la tierra
exactamente y los esquemas nos faltan los
compradores que están tan orgullosos de haber creado
como republicano en el Senado de la
la cámara alta puede ser otro ayer
que pensar de este cargo politico
decirle a rom exactamente qué interés en
fue lo más lejos posible
a la génesis en incluso eso podría
termino mismo voy o el kin se de
febrero precisamente por qué son
administradores sus democratas que
están presentando lo más destacado
conoce al presidente síguelo nace
Mar 10 6 horas en espera o en carpas o
que el antojo de natalia no hay basura o que el
spal para seguir presentando destacados
pero si espera salir o el clímax es
está presentando aspectos destacados mientras forma parte
de los demócratas para que se a Magliana
o transformar naresi sensorize maxima il
vuelta del pulso de la de fenza de la ex
el presidente piensa que a es hombre
critica a su expresidente
familiares del expresidente continúan
nole gusto mucho la diferencia que el
whey nyers a uva luz y al senado la
el entorno adecuado permanecerá intacto
estás solo brotes presente en reflejos y
por qué no debe a través de ighalo culpar a la santidad
el lugar donde usted o el político expuesto
estadistas 6 solas sosteniendo su costado
ben drento preguntas preguntas che
senadores tanto democratas como
republicano
las fórmulas de rosas en f cero no sólo
administradores de savoca los llanos se desnudan
proceso al representante sala
representando es el Partido Demócrata
que acusan al presidente del INPS
mente 4 ahora siento que eran canalis
aias que se presentara sexto jugo
en estas cuatro horas le pregunto que tomo
y cuyo CEO político el demócrata
arsenal por belmont tu vienes
presidente pro tempore del senado por la noche
el único que puede ramses formular el
escaleras apretadas vas ne parte de la
maneras de la escuela de senadores si termino esto
equipo de preguntas vendran los
testigos y don de pol se reincorporan a una
solo tono la única estancia de quien tú o
político porque país que le sigue un
sitara testigos si sitio a si mismo uno
a nuestro ex presidente porque las minas
en audiencia pública no son patrias de
super no negar venir al congreso un
declarar públicamente el varese que
no se guana sitar testigos preguntó si
teoria a una nueva ultimos comentarios a
una votación final que es común a ambos
hiperinstalación previamente analista
incluida la expropiación del 69 stare
diciendo que podría ser esto o el
equipo tienes que orero